um we were I touched on fasting is that
something you do it can be a useful tool
for people it's not magic it's you don't
have to do it for weight loss when
looking at the research on what's called
early time restricted feeding I think
that there are some potential metabolic
benefits to come with eating an earlier
dinner
and and not eating too late you know
into the evening for one because we're
diurnal creatures and so our metabolisms
are most PR are primed to be at their at
its most fired up during the daytime
hours so we're most insulin sensitive
during the day
um our metabolisms are higher right and
we have these clocks they're called
peripheral clocks all around our bodies
that are influenced by by when we eat
right and so there's this thinking that
eating too late at night can send can
sort of cause asynchrony in these clocks
and it can lead to impaired glucose
regulation heightened blood pressure
which is not good
um and so I don't have like a hard and
fast rule about fasting but I do think
it's generally better to eat earlier an
earlier dinner
um by like seven eight pm and and then
to not eat uh to not really eat
um after that the other thing the other
thing about fasting that makes it a
really powerful tool to improve weight
it's not more beneficial from a weight
loss standpoint as just regular old
calorie restriction but if you think
about the kinds of foods that most
people eat
um in front of their TVs at night like
after dinner like after dinner snacks
after dinner snacks tend to be carbs and
fat they tend not to be protein they
tend yeah nobody's snacking on like you
know fillets chunk of filet exactly so
if you if you adopt like an intermittent
fasting
um protocol for yourself right and you
skim off those three to four hundred
discretionary discretionary calories of
like what you would normally eat while
watching your favorite like Netflix show
chances are that's junk food right
totally I think at the end of the day
like personal preference really does
reign supreme if you want to eat
breakfast then by all means eat
breakfast if you don't like eating
breakfast breakfast you don't have to
eat breakfast you're told by the food
industry that breakfast is the most
important meal of the day but I think
that's really just a was meant just to
sell cereal there was a paper that came
out that looked at the conflicts of
interests among people who were invited
to contribute to the 2020 dietary
guidelines for Americans paper you know
every five years the experts get
together right yeah yeah like the food
pyramid the usdmi plate every five years
so that in 2020 95 of the committee
members had conflicts of interest with
Pharma with the food industry yeah get
in that bag right but like what who
suffers from that certainly not them
it's like the American people who just
continue to get more and more confused
right being steered more and more away
from ancestral foods like beef eggs fish
things like that right or liver liver
organ Meats yeah and towards these these
high margin
low protein Ultra processed equivalence
of like human pet food essentially
that's what the standard American diet
really is now comprised of primarily and
it's and I think it's a it's a huge
problem so the nutrition science to me
it's like obviously there's a lot of
like really important work that's being
done so I don't want to undermine it
completely but in many ways it is a
house of cards and um and so I've just
been here yeah I've been very
disillusioned by the whole the whole
Endeavor and I think it's it's really
sad and messed up and so that's why I
just continue to do what I do putting
out the best information that I can
in hopes of searing people in a
different direction what would Max's
food pyramid look like
oh that's a good question
I think that at the um at the base I
would definitely put high protein foods
I would put like I mean primarily animal
products but then I would also put like
the higher protein plant
foods for people who are so is there a
split in the middle yeah but I mean but
most of it it wouldn't be it wouldn't be
in the middle because
we know that animal protein is the
highest quality protein that exists in
nature I think that animal fat is like
is like great and beneficial to a point
But ultimately what I'm trying to do
with my choices is to prioritize protein
and
I would say that's the bottom yeah and
then one layer up would be fibrous
veggies like like don't tell the
carnivores but I think that cruciferous
vegetables are great oh I want to talk
about the carnivore situation yeah just
because like vegetables certain
vegetables don't work for certain people
doesn't mean that we have to throw the
baby out with the bath water like you
know I like certain vegetables and I
have no problem digesting them and and
right they're great for me right so I
think that the that the sort of one size
fits all like just eat more vegetables
that's not good advice either because
people like you know some people have
impaired gut function right they have
impaired microbiomes so like you really
do have to figure out what's going to
work best for you so what is the what is
what do you use as the mechanism to
decide what you should and shouldn't eat
when it comes to vegetables then
I think really it should be it's
subjective it should be about how you
feel you know it should be like
digestion bloating yeah yeah stuff like
that like that's not fun right nobody
wants to right like if you and if you
dramatically increase your fiber
consumption from one day to the next you
are gonna feel you know super bloated
and feel you know uncomfortable and
that's probably because you just haven't
yet cultivated the the like the
microbiome right like the bowel Flora to
contend with that sudden onslaught of
fiber but um people who are who are
consistently on high fiber diets and I'm
not saying that everybody listening to
this should go out and adopt a high
fiber diet but it's true that people
that are on high fiber diets
consistently like they don't have those
same kinds of symptoms like they adapt
because they develop the the gut Flora
to contend with that that fiber at the
end of the day though fiber is not an
essential nutrient so I don't I don't
tend to push fiber more than I think a
reasonable amount to support gut health
it's not essential huh so then if you
like I would think of fiber and you
think of regularity and so how do you
stay regular if you don't have fiber in
your diet what are other triggers that
keep things regular I don't think you
need fiber I mean I you know at this
point I've uh I've got some pretty close
friends that do the carnivore diet and
when when I ask them about their you
know their bathroom habits they they're
like it's fine in fact in fact many of
them have had uh like IBS see I think
that that's actually I think that I
think potentially for people with with
gut problems it can be a great
Elimination Diet to adopt super healing
at least temporarily because a lot of
these like you know animal products
anybody who's ever had like a
colonoscopy or any kind of like you know
bowel uh procedure performed that you
what you what you're typically
recommended is to is to go on a low um
residue diet for at least a few days
before the procedure and low residue
foods are foods like beef right eggs
white rice these are the the foods that
are easily broken down and absorbed
primarily in high up in the small
intestine right when people have gut
problems
like I think it's important for people
to like
every once in a while like check out
their stool right and it's it's often
the undigested food particles it's not
from animal like Foods right it's like
plants that their bodies didn't properly
break down right so I think for people
with gut problems it can be potentially
very useful to to do an Elimination Diet
and get rid of plants for at least a
time being for at least a time to allow
their guts to heal and then to bring
those Foods back eventually over time
one by one you know to see what what
works for you and what doesn't what do
you think like the top five vegetables
should be then to be in that sort of
next year up yeah well in your opinion
because it's different for everybody I
get it but like from a nutritional
standpoints for
micronutrients
um
vitamins minerals all that good stuff
what do you think the the five
big ones are well I would have to say
for one dark leafy greens and you know I
think kale can be I happen to like kale
it's so divisive so divisive yeah but
I'm not recommending that I'm saying
that like I like it I don't really have
you know any any major issue digesting
it but Dave asprey is just gonna burn
you on this one I think arugula is
phenomenal romaine lettuce yeah mixed
greens all great all great and super
nutrient dense because they're rich in
folate and vitamin C but they provide
very few calories which which increases
their nutrient density right by
definition and
um and we you know we know that people
who eat a bowl of dark leafy greens
every day have more youthful brains so
brains that perform up to 11 years
younger yeah about a bowl a serving and
a third I believe of dark leafy greens
every day
um that's becoming more and more
important for people like us yeah
and yeah super and again a very nutrient
dense food and so like whatever your
favorite dark leafy green is but okay
yeah iceberg lettuce doesn't count no
totally not it's just water yeah so dark
leafy greens that's one
well I would put
I would probably put like fruit there as
well like fruit goes in the vegetable
category okay yeah like in this I mean
we I guess we could divide that you know
like well fruit fruits and vegetables
like berries and avocados I think are
olives berries off berries avocados and
olives are amazing fruits
very like good data on them also cacao
Cacao is also a fruit mushrooms are good
alliums are great what are alliums so
garlic leeks onions shallots those are
all alliums great source of Prebiotic
fiber yeah that's why I get leaks I
didn't know why though I just heard it
and I was like oh get leaks it's a
Prebiotic leeks are bomb jicama Hickam
is great I love jicama
um
I happen to love fennel you know it's
like a fennel yeah
I love love love fennel I feel like
arugula
I love it raw yeah I don't cook it I
it's always raw arugula and fennel and
um Radicchio and
um
those are like the base ingredients yeah
so freaking good like I'm I'm obsessed
see I think that a lot of these
carnivores they grew up with like
parents that just didn't know how to
cook vegetables properly you know so
they were the kids that grew up on they
had like their whatever their diet was
at 12 years old you know they've just
stuck with and they learned at a certain
point that hot dogs weren't good for
them but in general it's like you know
they're grossed out by the idea of
eating vegetables but I grew up my mom
you know my mom was largely vegetarian
and um knew how to season vegetables
properly would put a ton of salt and
garlic on them and so I grew up really
enjoying veggies yeah I agree it's the
preparation of them and like the the
argument on that side would be like
would you eat it if it didn't have
anything on it you know and I'm like
kind of kind of
um Okay so we've got like meat of all
kinds including fish I'm sure right
proteins and you've got fruit
vegetables
what's next are we to Wine yet because
if we're not to like chocolate and wine
I just you know
chocolate we could put chocolate on on
the third tier I would put um I would
put like extra virgin olive oil maybe on
the third tier as well it's not it's not
a nutrient dense food but I think it is
a functional food in many ways
[Music]